echemos un vistazo a la nomenclatura de
los saludos de alquilo aquí tenemos un
alumno de alquilo y usaremos la
nomenclatura y un pack seguiremos los
mismos pasos que hemos usado en los
vídeos anteriores primero hay que
encontrar la cadena de carbonos más
larga cuantos carbonos hay en la cadena
más larga
aquí hay 1 2 3 4 5
y 77 carbonos es un eta no lo escribiré
por aquí
ya no
muy bien ahora vamos a enumerar lo
empezamos por el lado izquierdo de la
cadena o por el lado derecho
bueno aquí tenemos un halógeno y por acá
dos grupos al kilo debemos buscar que
los sustituye entes queden en los
números más pequeños en este caso si
empezamos por la izquierda el grupo al
kilo será el número dos si empezamos por
la izquierda
este es el carbono 1 y 2 aquí tenemos
otro grupo al kilo si empezamos por la
derecha el halógeno sería el número 3 y
como los números más pequeños son los
que ganan empezaremos por la izquierda
entonces tenemos 12
4 5 6 y 7 ahora cómo nombraremos a
nuestro grupo al kilo tenemos dos grupos
metilo uno en el carbono 2 y otro en el
carbono 4 así que es 124 dimetil
2 4
dime til
eta no y el halógeno se encuentra unido
al carbono 5 el bromo entonces se le
llama 5 bromo nos queda el 5 bromo 24
dimetil eta no ese es el nombre iupac
correcto para esta molécula y debemos
tomar en cuenta la regla del orden
alfabético por eso escribí el bromo
antes que el met y por qué la b para
antes que la n
así nos queda el nombre hagamos otro
pongamos un cloro por aquí y un bromo
por acá
muy bien cuál es la cadena de carbonos
más larga para este caso por aquí
tenemos 1 2 3 4 y 5 carbonos así que es
un pantano
ven tan ahora de qué lado empezamos la
numeración bueno si empezamos por la
izquierda el bromo quedaría en el número
1 y si empezamos por la derecha el grupo
al kilo tendría el número 2 nos conviene
empezar por la izquierda tenemos el
carbono 12
4 y 5 el grupo metilo ahora está unido
al carbono 4 es el 4 metido entonces
tenemos 4 metil ventana y ahora vamos
con los halógenos el bromo está en la
posición 1 y el cloro en la 3 por orden
alfabético el bromo va antes que el
cloro escribamos el cloro 3
cloro
y a un lado escribamos el bromo 1
pero amo
nos ha quedado 1 bromo 3 cloro 4 metil
pantano ese es el nombre para esta
molécula muy bien hagamos otro esta
molécula
así
sigamos los mismos pasos aquí tenemos el
carbono 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
es un hexano
es sano pero tenemos un problema porque
si empezamos desde la izquierda el bromo
nos queda en el número 2 y si empezamos
por la derecha
el grupo metilo queda en el carbono
número 2 cómo lo resolvemos bueno
basándonos en el orden alfabético entre
el bromo y el metil la p le gana a la m
eso significa que empezaremos por el
lado izquierdo
este es el carbono 1 2 3
4 5 y 6
basándonos en el orden alfabético nos
queda el grupo metilo en el carbono 5
así que tenemos 5
y el bromo está en el carbono 2 nos
queda 2 bromo y el nombre completo-
iupac de esta molécula es 2 bromo 5
methylhexanamine serio química
involucrada bueno
si les dan algo como esto
una molécula con una cuña y un átomo en
este caso de yodo primero hay que
nombrar a la molécula no se preocupen
por la stereo química eso lo pondremos
al final primero identifiquemos la
cadena de carbonos más larga este sería
1 2
45 es un pantano verdad
tano
de que el lado de la cadena empezamos la
numeración quiero tener el número más
pequeño posible para los sustituye entes
para este caso desde la derecha uno dos
tres cuatro cinco así los sustituye
entes quedan en números pequeños sólo
tenemos un mitin y un yodo por el orden
alfabético la n va antes que la y
entonces el met y nos queda primero como
el yodo está en la posición 2 entonces
nos queda 2 yodo pentano y el metil está
en la posición 3 nos ha quedado 3 metil
2 yodo ventana ahora sí que este número
es r o s
veamos la prioridad por el aumento del
número atómico el más grande tiene la
prioridad en este caso el número más
grande es el yodo es el número uno este
es mi centro quiral y recuerden que aquí
hay un hidrógeno unido a este carbono
ese es el número cuatro el yodo es el
número uno y el hidrógeno es el número
cuatro tiene la menor prioridad ahora
tenemos un grupo alquiló a la izquierda
y un grupo metilo a la derecha el grupo
al kilo tiene la segunda prioridad más
alta y el grupo metilo la tercera si nos
vamos en el sentido de las agujas del
reloj tenemos al y somero r
este es el r3 metil 2 yodo ventana así
es como hay que nombrar a los saludos y
al kilo usando la nomenclatura iupac
algunas veces pueden encontrarse con los
nombres comunes por ejemplo
para esta molécula en lugar de nombrarla
enumerando la cadena y los sustituye
entes que hay en ella se encontrarán con
el nombre cloruro de éter butilo ese es
el nombre común para esta molécula y es
tan común que le encontrarán más así que
con el nombre iupac por lo que nosotros
también usaremos este nombre para otra
molécula como por ejemplo para los
saludos de alquilo pequeños se utiliza
mucho la nomenclatura común
este es bromuro de etilo
así que esencialmente se le da el nombre
al halógeno y al grupo al kilo como
pueden ver para estos dos casos la
nomenclatura común se conforma con el
halógeno y el grupo al kilo al que está
unido el bromuro de tilo puede llamarse
bromo etano bromuro de tilo es el nombre
común pero si quieren pueden usar el
nombre iupac cualquiera de los dos está
bien
último que necesitamos hacer para los
saludos de alquilo es hablar de su
clasificación ya hemos hablado de
clasificaciones anteriormente como por
ejemplo para los alcoholes y en el caso
de los saludos de alquilo es muy
parecido por ejemplo si tenemos un
halógeno que está unido a este carbono y
queremos clasificar el allure o del kilo
sólo hay que ver a cuántos carbonos está
unido a este carbono está unido al
halógeno y a otro carbono eso lo
convierte en un alero de alquilo
primario hacemos lo mismo para esta
situación
este es el carbono que está unido al
halógeno cuántos carbonos están unidos a
este bueno hay dos carbonos es un alumno
de alquilo secundario
secundario y luego tenemos este caso una
vez más hay que observar a cuántos
carbonos está unido aquí hay uno dos y
tres es un al 1 del kilo terciario en el
caso del cloruro de ttr butilo este es
nuestro al 1 del kilo hay 123 carbonos
es un al 1 del kilo terciario y para el
bromuro de tilo este carbono está unido
a otro carbono es un ejemplo de una luro
de alquilo primario este es el primer
paso cuando lleven a cabo reacciones con
alumnos de alquilo identifiquen su
clasificación